su corazón bombea sangre hacia su
cerebro a través de vasos sanguíneos en
su cuello estos vasos sanguíneos
llamados arterias se ramifican en
arterias incluso más pequeñas que llevan
la sangre a sus células cerebrales
algunas de estas arterias pequeñas se
unen a otras para formar una trayectoria
conocida como el círculo de Willis
las paredes de las arterias contienen un
músculo especial y capas elásticas que
las ayudan a adaptarse a la sangre que
bombea a través de ellas
a veces las enfermedades lesiones o
defectos de nacimiento pueden provocar
un espacio débil en la pared de las
arterias en el círculo de Willis
Estos espacios débiles usualmente se
forman donde se ramifican las arterias
con el tiempo la presión del fluido de
la sangre a través de las arterias
acentúa más el espacio débil
la presión sanguínea constante puede
provocar que el espacio débil se infle y
forme un bulto llamado aneurisma
cerebral este aneurisma cerebral es el
tipo más común llamado un aneurisma
sacular o tipo vaya
con el paso del tiempo el aneurisma
puede crecer y empujar tejido cerebrales
cercanos o nervios
la sangre puede también gotear desde la
aneurisma
si su pared se vuelve muy delgada el
aneurisma puede reventar o romperse y
derramar sangre de alta presión
alrededor de su cerebro
la sangre presiona su tejido cerebral y
puede provocar lesión a sus células
cerebrales los químicos en la sangre
escapada pueden irritar a otras arterias
del cerebro y pueden provocar que se
reduzca
como resultado su cerebro puede
hincharse conduciendo a una grave lesión
cerebral
los síntomas comunes de la ruptura de un
aneurisma incluyen
dolores de cabeza graves y repentinos a
veces llamados cefalea en trueno
problemas con la vista como visión
borrosa o doble
náuseas y vómitos
un cuello adolorido o rígido o confusión
un aneurisma cerebral sin romperse puede
no provocar síntomas pero aneurismas
grandes que no se han roto pueden
provocar los siguientes síntomas dolor
de cabeza y dolor cerca o detrás del ojo
visión doble o borrosa
un párpado caído
entumecimiento debilidad en uno de los
lados de la cara
un aneurisma cerebral roto es una
emergencia médica si está teniendo
síntomas Busca inmediatamente atención
médica
si tiene un aneurisma cerebral roto su
médico puede recomendar clips
quirúrgicos o espirales endovasculares
para los clips quirúrgicos su cirujano
hará una abertura en su cráneo cerca de
su aneurisma
y colocará un pequeño clip de metal en
el tallo que conecta el aneurisma a su
arteria el clip bloquea el flujo de
sangre en su aneurisma
en las espirales endovasculares su
médico colocará un tubo de plástico
llamado un catéter en una arteria grande
en su ingle
utilizando una vista de rayos x en vivo
su médico hará avanzar el catéter a
través de sus arterias hasta que alcance
la aneurisma
a través del catéter su médico insertará
uno o más cables flexibles en su
aneurisma
los cables Se enrollarán y provocarán
que se forme un coágulo sanguíneo dentro
de su aneurisma lo cual bloquea el
aneurisma del resto de su arteria
en una forma similar si tiene un
aneurisma cerebral que no está roto su
médico puede recomendar los clips
quirúrgicos o espirales endovasculares
además si su aneurisma es pequeño y no
provoca dolor u otros síntomas
su médico puede observar su aneurisma
por un periodo de tiempo antes de
realizar cualquiera de estos
procedimientos